since we started in 2002 we grew from a
very small class of about eight
full-time students to now over 160
students full time part time masters and
PhD program what I found interesting
about this particular program was that
the quark classes were at a minimum and
are the actual specialization that we
wanted to do was left up to us so we
could really explore several different
areas and that really helped me in my
career and I actually felt like I was
going to go back to school because of
the time and energy investment I really
wanted to make a difference in my career
so I was actually looking for something
that was going to be a little bit more
technical I would say that this is a
great kind of bridge program or
transitionary program if if you know a
technical professional looking to learn
more business acumen or cross over to
the business side or build that
background this is definitely a great
program to do that almost every person
that I came across in each of the
faculty and the peers were so intense
and involved it was a very dynamic
environment a lot of discussion going on
about the very current events and what's
happening in an industry what I think is
really unique about our program is how
flexible a program is for professionals
and our curriculum is designed so that
students going through the program can
take what they're learning in our
classroom and then apply it on the job I
have a role where I have to travel
pretty much one or two weeks every month
and so you know the fact that Carnegie
Mellon provides the capability to attend
class remotely has been really really
helpful the faculty here at Carnegie
Mellon is extremely high quality they
all come from great backgrounds and have
such extensive experience either with
industry or with research or in their
own field and that is an amazing
resource to be able to learn from and to
work with you're being taught by someone
who has actually encountered the same
types of problems that you're trying
all for the same types of goals at your
setting with your projects it's you feel
like you have an experienced co-worker
working alongside you almost I love
working with my students at some
assessment or the interactions talking
about issues they have at work talking
about issues they have on the team and
coaching them and how to solve those
problems students work in teams and they
actually have the professor meet with
them on a weekly basis generally so they
get very close almost one-on-one
coaching from the faculty member and so
you get to practice in a safe setting
what it's like to actually negotiate
with your peers take different roles
make sure that everybody in a team is
accountable it's been fantastic to have
full-time students on campus and one of
the things that those students are able
to do in addition to having these small
classes is that they also in some cases
have the opportunity to do research
assistants it was great to be able to
while being a full-time student because
not only was I able to learn all of
these amazing concepts in class design
decisions etc but then I was also able
to apply them to a real-world project
into to my research into the research
assistantship I think there's a
community here and if it wasn't for this
program I can't say that I would have
been introduced and exposed to a lot of
the individuals that I've met here I
think there's a tremendous amount of
networking value in being a part of the
alumni community according to now and I
don't even feel like I'm in school I
feel like I'm some kind of a support
group for entrepreneurs that you know
just everybody is so excited about what
I'm doing and so it just feels really
moving the whole program was so
transformative that I actually through
the course decided to leave my job at
Sun Microsystems
for 20 years and start my own software
company being from Carnegie Mellon it
helps a lot to start your own company
because you already have the Carnegie
Mellon name behind you the good thing
about being out here is that if you have
a idea you can go ahead and make a
prototype get some other people on board
who are interested in the same idea
develop it a little more and get some
funding and turn it into small start-up
there are expectations of Carnegie
Mellon grads that we in the industry
have you know we know in the technical
program they've really been pushed very
hard to be excellent since I joined the
program I got promoted to run a very
sizable engineering organization with
about 120 people and i will have been
totally overwhelmed and I not involved
in the program
you